[Music]
you have to remember his country at one
point four billion people four times the
population size of the United States
China has become a major market for many
of the American companies China has been
known as the factory of the world s
pours for a long time or was the engine
of China's economic growth along with a
lot of investments representing about 50
percent of GDP no other country has
invested so much as China in the past
ten years largely because China has the
highest the savings rate in the world
when I say no other country has invested
as much I mean any country at any time
in history at any stage of their
industrialization process but China's
growth model has run into a wall as
farce peaked about ten years ago
representing about 36 percent of GDP to
today it has fallen to 19 percent of GDP
so s port is no longer the engine of
economic growth and if you look at
investments it has come down as well so
what China is doing is to shift his
growth model growth engine away from as
most investments to private consumption
which 10 years ago represented about 35
percent of GDP in today's on a 50
percent so for American companies like
Apple China is no longer the factory of
the world it has become a market of the
world in Chinese market has become very
significant for Apple is 20% of his
sales about 50 billion dollars for a
company like Qualcomm is 65 percent of
his sales
skyworks technology is more than 80
percent I think it's 84 percent of their
sales and then you have Starbucks you
have Boeing and all these companies have
very large market shares in China
General Motors today sells more cars in
China than in the United States Mexico
and Canada combined that is General
Motors sells more cars in China then
they sell in North America so that's how
significant the China market has become
Chinese primary consumption now is about
five trillion dollars more than 10% of
the entire primary consumption
expenditure last year so which the view
China has a market of the world that's
supposed to be the factory of the world
I think there are many misperceptions in
the United States about China and
there's no question about it I think so
much it's written about China yet so
little is understood about this country
and that's why I thought my book heart
of the Gobi is quite relevant my view is
that if you don't understand the modern
history most recent history of a country
it won't be able to understand the
country it's like here in the United
States if you don't know about the Civil
War if you don't know about a civil
right movement then you won't be able to
understand the United States so I think
to know something about the history of
China especially the most recent history
in our lifetime will be very useful to
dispel the misperception and a better
understanding of that country
[Music]